[Music]
jerry's in new york hey jerry welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dude how are y'all doing today
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
yeah so i'm curious what your opinions
are on moving and taking a pay cut for a
partner
so uh low context my girlfriend of about
a year and a half just finished her
master's program in education and now
she wants to teach english in europe for
a while before officially starting her
career in the states and she wants me to
join her and my job will let me go
they'll help with visas and everything
but
the pay is location base so i'd be
dropping from about 125k in new york to
about 75k in yeah you love this and also
i do
how long you've been dating
50k
and a half a year and a half this is a
serious dead gun relationship 50 000
bucks
yeah
and uh so i'm also about like two years
into my mortgage on my apartment here
and i wasn't really planning on leaving
until i met her um so like now i'm like
ready to lay route to new york kind of
but she's done with it because it's way
too expensive for teachers in new york
um and she's not sure if she wants to
live in new york when she comes back to
the states so it kind of feels like this
decision this ultimatum do i sacrifice
like my life my income and everything
well i don't like the word ultimatum
where there's 50 000 worth of love
involved
is that how it was presented to you
either you move or this is over
she definitely like is done with the
city and like ready for like another
place to live and we do like traveling
together so
this might be more into her than she is
into you
i said you're more into her than she is
into you
i i don't think i'm making sure she's
skunk she's gonna ditch new york and you
with it you're gonna ditch new york to
follow her i don't know man i'm just a
oh man i ain't dated in years i don't
know how to tell you what to do with
this um you gotta decide how much this
is going to work
i if you were my uh little brother or my
nephew or something i would tell you
don't go unless you're married i agree
and i would say
then it's worth a sacrifice now this is
a bet for life it's not a bet for a
weekend fling in europe what if she's
not giving up everything
we don't know what's going to happen
here
hope you can match up to that whoa